- What's up, guys?
Just signing some books,
you're about to watch
the session we just had,
I'll be honest with you,
there's a lot of pressure on Jason,
I think there's at least
four viral individual clips.
This is probably the long form one,
but Jason, I'm not joking
around, fuckin' find 'em.
(laughing)
Believe this or not because
in the Gary Vee land,
there's one kind of perception,
but in my corporate land,
I'm massively underestimated
by our clients of Intermedia.
'Cause I don't look the part.
'Cause I don't have this degree or that.
I use it for my advantage,
but I have a big difference
than you, I won my business,
but on the client side,
I still have to sell
them, and sometimes I use
the underestimating as an advantage.
Sometimes when I know
I'm being underestimated,
and I come into a room, I'll
go hard on depth and stake
just to make them realize
what's actually going on here.
Sometimes I'll, mm-hm,
sometimes I'll mic drop
not from pontificating and
sizzle big profound statement me,
I'll go into some real fuckin'
hardcore detail real fast
about business that makes
them real uncomfortable
because I might know their business better
than they know their business.
When you're being
underestimated, speak facts.
- [Female] When reaching
out to influencers
with little to no money and no leverage,
how can you bring them value?
- By asking them.
- And get them to agree.
- Just asking?
- Straight up.
- And see what they say?
- 100%, and just knowing back
to the same game I told him,
people are like Gary, I hit up, I DM'ed
all the influencers like you told me,
nobody responded, I'm like
how many, they're like 130,
I'm like good, there's
about 9 million more.
- [Male] Right.
- [Female] And you just
say will you help me?
- No, because that's not the
way to position it, right,
because most people won't
answer that because somebody
who's got an audience,
that's all they see.
I would say how can I help you?
- [Female] That was my question.
- You see where I'm goin'?
- [Female] Yeah.
- Like, yo I fuck with
you, how can I help you?
- [Female] But then if you
don't have any leverage...
- Yes you do, you have your time.
You never know.
D Rock didn't have any leverage.
D Rock asked me four times,
and then finally I said,
yeah, fine, make me a fuckin' video.
Not even in that mindset,
and then this all happened because of it.
That's real, that's
real, that's the story.
That's the story, he asked
me four times, I want to make
a video for you, he was a video
guy, I wasn't making content
like that then, but it was in my mind,
and by the fourth time, I was
like you know what, fuck it,
okay, make me a free video,
show me, here we are.
Now he's the fuckin' the word that people,
people literally say,
literally a fuckin' verb.
(laughter)
Literally, people are like
my D Rock's name is Rick.
I'm like you know D Rock's a name.
(laughter)
You know what I mean?
It's real, and you know
what, I said this at the time
to D Rock, I said you're
gonna impact people,
do you know how awesome it is for people
that love to do it to do it?
You know how many people
wanted to make documentaries
their whole lives, yet only
74 people a year get to do 'em
and now 74 thousand people
a year get to do it?
All it takes is one person.
- [Female] I'm a natural
introvert, so networking
is important, but I'm
not the kind of person
that walks into a room and just...
- There's only two ways to do it.
- How do you do it?
- You either force your way
through it and incrementally
get better over time
by deploying patience or you outsource it.
You're more than welcome to
give up 20% of your business
to the most charismatic friend
you know that you trust.
You are.
Right, you are.
- You are.
- Most people don't want to
give up 20% of their business,
you know, but I'm like 20% of 0 is 0.
And if you're not gonna
be able to network,
and that's important, then
what the fuck are we talkin'
about here?
(laughter)
Right?
I like results, that's why I win.
Not how I want the results to happen.
People have ideology of how
they want it to go down.
I just want it to go down.
I think one of the biggest
mistakes that so many people
in youth make is lack of
patience and not willing
to pay their dues.
Like, young man with the new business,
I always hear, he hasn't said it,
but a lot of people are
like Gary, I'm not getting
a lot of clients, everyone's saying no,
I'm like that's what should be happening.
- [Male] Yeah it took us six
months to get our first client.
- That's right, that's
what should be happening.
Who the fuck are you?
You just graduated school,
I don't fuckin' trust you.
- It's fine, it's fine.
- That means you love
the process, that's the
shit I'm talkin' about.
You know how fun it was for me
for five hours a day on Twitter?
You know how hopeful I am that
this is gonna be fun for you?
'Cause if it's fun, you
got business comin'.
If it's Gary told me to
do it, and you're doin' it
but you hate it, it's gonna die.
People don't like to jump
'cause they think it hurts
their resume, crazy, crazy.
I'm tryin' to get so
many kids out of this.
Nobody gives a fuck if you
were at a place in six months,
especially when I ask
you if I'm sittin' here,
you're like it wasn't right for me,
I have enough self-awareness,
the culture wasn't right,
my boss's boss wasn't right,
and I knew I could do better,
and I wanted to be in an
environment, you've won me over
for leaving in six months,
not I'm cynical to you.
Resume jumping is some 1984 shit.
So that's number one, and number two,
some people don't have the self-confidence
of getting another job if they get fired
so they keep their mouth shut.
But you don't have to be
disrespectful when you talk.
That's how I've won.
Hey guys, thank you so much for watching
my video on YouTube.
I wanted to jump in here at
the end because I'm working
on a ridiculously
important project for me,
and I have a funny feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at all or
know anybody that drinks wine
at all, please go to empathywines.com
right now and sign up
for a subscription,
whether it's a three pack,
whether it's a six pack, or
whether it's a whole case
of each for the year.
If you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year,
please sign up for Club Empathy.
This project means the world to me,
I could really use your support.